[Music]
bart
growing up have you ever met anyone
with the same eccentricity as your
mom as my mom yeah [ __ ] i don't even
know if your mom's found your mom
your aunt yeah
my mom and her sister are off they're
together the world's over
it gets crazier it's just double crazy
so my mom i wish you invited your aunt
so my mom is actually like a watered
down
version of my aunt how is that even
possible and my aunt
and my mom is a more pleasant ver so
like this is how bad my honest like if i
go to taiwan
and my aunt comes over and i'm like oh i
want some boba
she takes me downstairs okay let's go
get some bubble but the minute we're
walking into the bubble shop the person
that's there and sees my aunt they're
like
oh [ __ ] they're like like she leaves
that feeling with you my mom
she has the same like uh like
quirkiness yeah but she doesn't leave a
bad taste in her mouth
my aunt does what does she do then so
she's like the negative version
yeah she's like darth vader just trying
to bargain an event like oh if i buy
five do i get the six one free just like
random [ __ ] like
it's just it just makes every
transaction like three times longer and
more difficult than it needs to be for
everything interesting more precisely
does your
aunt also do drugs like the dancing
stuff
that your mom does and like oh does she
make up her own exercises
like how your mom does she used to beat
me up that's not the question she's like
she's like i need to you know if i come
here
she does she doesn't seem to be that way
but she's still when i was a kid that's
why she's negative because your mom
be making up her own funny [ __ ] and
she'll be like you want to do judo
and then she's like just throwing me on
the ground and then later on i found out
she never
took judo but she's just beating me for
real
she's like she gets home she's angry
yeah like y'all do some judo
all right hell yeah do some judo and lay
down like hey did you ever learn judo
nope i'm like what the [ __ ] just
slamming me on the ground
well the reason why i ask is uh a little
backstory for you if you don't know
bart's mom likes to make up her own
exercises and does a lot of that
dancing next level [ __ ] next level [ __ ]
well there's a man in china that has
invented his own form of exercising
that's probably good it's probably
really good all right here we go
whoa oh it's like that one girl the dog
girl
it's like a dog girl he's walking like a
lemur or something a monkey
that's pretty cool that seems fine
there's a whole community of people that
walk like that normally
but like actually imitate a monkey oh
that was flexible dude
good for him he's very friendly
it's kind of like kung fu do you know
kung fu is based off animals and stuff
yeah
why does he look like a chinese monkey
dude this is next level right here hey
lions like a monkey
he climbs like i'll walk like that if i
could climb like that that's dope the
fact that
it's happening he's older he's an older
man what she's like 30.
if i could do that i'd be purposely like
playing like frisbee by a tree so i
could get it stuck
all the ladies are gonna love you dude
but it's tight workout was just walking
that i wouldn't like it but the climbing
part seems dope
and this part he's like doing some
thrusts
how tall is his girlfriend that's the
thing i don't know he has to climb up to
kiss her yeah
i can't hear people talking i gotta
listen oh it's not important
honestly from from the history of
translation
uh for bar he he always says that then
we let him hear it and he never tells
the [ __ ]
people are like people what did he say
oh [ __ ] that's just [ __ ] crazy
then we play it again and then we're all
waiting to hear like this profound
something and you're like i didn't
understand no this time i heard this
this time i understood that should we
try it should we actually try yeah
just somebody be quiet just just let
them translate it
all right i'll do it in real time
he's like what is this called he goes
it's like some animal exercise
[Music]
he said it's like some animal actually
my friend
i don't know which animal though too
specifically was there an accent do you
have an accident that's why no no no no
it's like almost someone going like i
don't want to say orangutang in chinese
so so it's like some sort of primate
animal but i don't know that specific
term
oh so you don't know okay i thought he
didn't i was like
because he's speaking like way too
specifically you know oh i see i see
it's a marsupial one yeah let's see
some sort of analysis so far so good
yeah did the interviewer ever say
do you need to climb up to kiss your
girlfriend we'll find out all right
i love working out
i love watching monkeys and i like how
much fun they have
i feel like you're lying
[Music]
can you pause real quick something about
something expanding
about something he said i love
did he really say that no he says he
loves monkeys and he loves watching him
he loves how much fun that they're
having and they says the difference
between my exercise
and normal exercise are you lying i said
something expanding i don't know what
like it's like another word again it's
another word okay but that's
he seems like a really nice either my
hair doesn't seem really sweet yeah my
lungs or my hips or something but it's
just
once again it's like words that i don't
i don't know how to say pelvis in
i think he could swing like a monkey too
you know like the monkeys he wears
gloves
so so he might be able to like you know
you know like we don't have like you
know the calluses that monkey would have
i think i would trust him to get
coconuts
oh yeah have you seen the filipino guys
they get
like a belt or like like yeah around
their feet and then they hug the tree
with it
and they climb to the top and [ __ ]
machetes up the coconuts they do like
their shirt
hawaii too we've seen that all right
yeah
they put it around both feet and then
they use so here's the treat and then
the
the the shirt like wrapped around the
strap almost and then they just keep
jumping on top and it keeps going oh
okay okay i think i have seen that okay
yeah but then it's scary because
you know it's like a palm tree it's just
one but these kind of trees you can like
fall and maybe grab something he's
tarzan
i wonder if he's ever grabbed onto a
weak branch and say oh [ __ ]
oh
but he's like super like confident he
was like this was the one i wanted
this is the brand yeah so this guy mr
monkey guy he's the monkey king dude
monkey king
and he had a lot of ailments like
tendonitis and all that kind of stuff
and then he moved to the to the city and
then once he got to the city he was like
well farming in and of itself was kind
of like
his like his daily movement that he
needed to do to stay
you know active active yeah and so he
designed
he he didn't want to do tai chi he
didn't want to do the job he's like
that's just
lame yeah let me look like a monkey you
don't want to do the asian exercises or
you're doing like that kind of [ __ ] or
whatever
so you decided to do some monkey
exercises
and um did he make that [ __ ] up or you
watched like someone else do it
yeah he watched monkeys baby dude yeah
you it came from you all right right he
did watch monkeys
did they say how old he is yeah you know
what i don't know he looks like okay i'm
gonna guess he looks like he's uh
44. i'm gonna say 50s
really oh [ __ ] 50s he looks like late
50s to me 850.
well you're reading it don't do the same
way what is it 50.
damn it oh 50 straight 50 straight you
know what's funny you know how like they
be like asians don't raisin right
and then so um so my friend had a
personal driver in vietnam
and we're like driving and then he was
like
guys like how do you think i am right
and i'm all like
he just brings it up this guy's probably
like 65
like he's pretty [ __ ] old like but i
was thinking like maybe he's like
you know 70 but then like he's he's he
looks 60
see that you were doing him a favor yeah
yeah so i was like yeah 64
65 and then he was like uh i'm actually
48.
oh [ __ ]
i was like i was like why is your driver
why does he look so [ __ ] old i'm in
the sun man
he's probably like damn i probably look
young yeah that's probably why he asked
well i feel like he looked like a
grandpa driving
dude yeah and then like what i was like
why did he even think that he looked
young and cool like what is wrong with
this dude
because i was like i thought he was a
[ __ ] grandpa and then um
i was like well i thought agents didn't
raise him like what is this he looked
like we know a couple people that reason
i know but it's just something that i
thought i was good at telling asian
did you say after he said 148. no i said
no i asked i was like why the [ __ ] does
he look so old why are you just turning
your friend
you ignored him all together well
because the guy that's driving he's not
going to know english
so i just told him you wanted your
friend to translate to him why do you
look so old
even ruder well because i was shocked
double down because i was shocked okay
because at first i was like
i thought so you dug a hole and you're
like [ __ ] it all in
dig deeper why is he asking because i'm
thinking okay he's probably like
70 right or something and then and then
i'm thinking
well you know you want to say like yeah
you look 63 bro
and then he's like yeah still got it
right and then like
i didn't think it was gonna be 48 like
what the [ __ ] right
i didn't even think he was younger than
50 no [ __ ] way if you see this guy
you'll be like no no way
that's [ __ ] up what's his fault for
asking and then
well i had to know because i was like
this isn't normal like why the [ __ ]
is he so old and then they just went on
this discussion for a while
right and i was like damn he's telling
him his life story and he turns around
and goes
he was severely ill as a child and then
he had to work out to kind of like get
his life back
and then now we go to the gym once in a
while so he feels like confident about
his body and i was just like
well why did he ask what if there was a
further gap
what if there was a further gap what if
before it was he was 48 but he looked
like he was 90.
and now it's closer it's 48 i was like
64. so it's in progress maybe
he was just like on the other side of it
well he's been going to the gym lately
with my buddy
so he feels more confident i think
so he's probably just like notice any
different oh and you shot him down
hard i didn't know that's what he was
looking for my friend was cracking the
[ __ ] up though
he was like you think he looks 60 i was
like yeah you look 60 something
don't ever do that with women no i think
with women you're going to be like a 80
year old and you're like
girl you 21. oh you flirting with it oh
yeah
but also that's a don't sleep on 80
asian conversation you're allowed to
have
you can go why are you so fat that's
true oh i tell you why i'm fat
you know you but like yeah i'll tell you
what you could you could you could ask
those hard
questions in like asian conversations
and no one's gonna take it personal and
you actually talk about wait so you're
not supposed to ask a lady her age
uh yeah american even mexican yeah you
don't do that
no one's if you're talking to them you
have to make sure they're at least
legal um what i mean if you think that
in the first place
i would say get the [ __ ] out well no
just to be safe because i
like well because especially his age the
girls around his age you got to watch
out because girls are like oh this is
for older women like if they're
younger like that yeah this is for women
that you know are like past like 30 or
40. because i was talking about a girl
recently and she was like oh like
meeting a 40 year old woman like hold on
what's your id
[Laughter]
i was i was tired she was like oh i
don't like typically date uh guys is all
of you and i was like
and i was like i know i'm older than you
though or i'm not you look older
yeah yeah i get that but she was i'm
saying she
look she is older than i am but she
thought i was way older than her and
you're surprised
because you're surprised but it's just
also like because she was it's just
beautiful if you didn't have i don't
have a beard now
no it's a beard that's more of a beard
than i could ever grow it's your body
your neck and your face
okay but i know how old i am you know
she thought i was 35
yeah so everyone is like 35. i know
you look older than casey i know all i'm
saying is
is sometimes you have to ask the age and
that's fine
if they're in their 20s you know why i
think in asian culture it's okay to
un like know the age it's because you
want to understand where you
were how you supposed to act with them
because like
obviously a grandma you don't need to
know her age right because you know that
she's your superior
but like if i meet someone like nelson
right um the first thing i would ask is
like oh how old are you
well in korean culture uh because i did
a lot of studying there
um not there in korea but i studied a
lot um they asked you what year you were
born
they don't ask you your birth so they're
like what year were you born and then
that's how you know what the hierarchy
is and then you know
how to treat someone if you want to
treat them like [ __ ] and bully them or
you got to suck up to them
[Music]
bye
[Music]